- Bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea
Informației și Computației Cuantice.
Mă numesc John Watrous și
sunt Directorul Tehnic pentru IBM Quantum Education.
Aceasta este a patra lecție din serie și este ultima
lecție din prima unitate a seriei despre bazele
informației cuantice.
Până acum, am discutat despre
cum funcționează informația cuantică atât pentru sisteme individuale, cât și pentru sisteme multiple, am analizat modelul
quantum circuit,
și am observat unele
limitări fundamentale ale informației cuantice.
Pe parcurs, am
întâlnit câteva concepte matematice importante,
inclusiv produse tensoriale și produse interioare, și vom continua
să folosim acele concepte și vom introduce și altele noi
pe măsură ce avem nevoie de ele.
În această lecție, ne vom concentra
pe trei exemple fundamentale importante: quantum teleportation, superdense coding și jocul CHSH,
care se mai numește și inegalitatea CHSH și nu este întotdeauna descris ca un joc.
Acestea nu sunt doar exemple
întâmplătoare menite să ilustreze cum funcționează informația cuantică, ele sunt cu adevărat elemente cheie ale fundației
informației cuantice și
apar în contexte diferite și uneori neașteptate în cadrul informației
și computației cuantice.
Entanglementul joacă un rol cheie în toate cele trei
exemple, și de fapt, entanglementul este cel care le face să funcționeze
și le face interesante. Astfel, această lecție va reprezenta, într-un fel, prima noastră oportunitate de a
vedea entanglementul în acțiune
și de a începe să explorăm ce anume face entanglementul atât de interesant.
Prezentarea generală a
lecției este foarte simplă: vom parcurge unul câte unul
cele trei exemple pe care tocmai le-am menționat:
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding și jocul CHSH.
Vom discuta ce sunt acestea și ce le face interesante și vom parcurge analize care explică exact cum funcționează
la nivel matematic.
Înainte de a ajunge la primul
dintre cele trei exemple, care este quantum teleportation, este potrivit să facem mai întâi
cunoștință cu personajele,
Alice și Bob, în caz că nu
ești familiarizat cu ele.
Alice și Bob sunt nume
date unor entități sau agenți ipotetici în sisteme, protocoale, jocuri,
și orice alt tip de interacțiune pe care ai vrea s-o iei în considerare și care implică schimbul de informații.
Au apărut pentru prima dată în
contextul criptografiei în anii 1970, dar
convenția de a folosi aceste nume în acest mod a devenit foarte comună
într-un context mult mai larg de atunci. Ideea este că acestea
sunt nume foarte comune, cel puțin în unele părți ale lumii, și încep cu literele A și B,
și este, de asemenea, convenabil
să ne referim la Alice și Bob folosind pronumele ea și el, doar pentru concizie.
De obicei ne imaginăm că Alice și Bob se află în locații diferite și că au obiective
și comportamente diferite
în funcție de subiectul despre care vorbim.
De exemplu, dacă vorbim
despre comunicare, adică despre transmiterea informațiilor, putem decide
că Alice este expeditorul
și Bob este receptorul
oricărei informații transmise.
Uneori Alice și Bob
cooperează, ceea ce este foarte tipic, dar uneori
concurează sau pot avea obiective diferite, care pot
sau nu pot fi compatibile
unele cu altele, dar
toate acestea trebuie să fie clarificate în situația dată.
Desigur, ei reprezintă abstracțiuni și nu neapărat ființe umane reale.
Putem introduce, de asemenea,
personaje suplimentare, cum ar fi Charlie și
Diane sau nume diferite care reprezintă
personas diferite, cum ar fi Eve
pentru un interceptor sau Mallory pentru cineva care se comportă malițios,
în funcție de context.
În orice caz, vom vedea Alice și Bob în toate cele trei
exemple pe care le vom discuta în această lecție și din când în când
pe parcursul restului seriei. Voi face, de asemenea, câteva
comentarii despre entanglement înainte de a trece la cele trei exemple.
În lecția a doua, am întâlnit acest exemplu de stare entanglată a doi qubiți.
Este una dintre cele patru stări Bell, și s-ar putea spune că
această stare particulară reprezintă exemplul arhitipic
al unei stări cuantice entanglate.
Am întâlnit, de asemenea,
acest exemplu de stare probabilistică a doi biți.
Este analogă cu
starea entanglată într-un anumit sens, dar nu este entanglată,
entanglementul este un fenomen
exclusiv cuantic,
practic prin definiție.
Există o definiție matematică precisă a ceea ce este entanglementul și, practic, ceea ce spune acea definiție
este că entanglementul
este o corelație cuantică non-clasică.
Dar asta nu este prea
util la nivel intuitiv, este o definiție a entanglementului în termenii a ceea ce entanglementul nu este,
și probabil de aceea
este destul de dificil să explici ce este entanglementul și ce îl face special
în termeni intuitivi.
Când oamenii încearcă să
explice ce este entanglementul în termeni intuitivi,
auzi adesea explicații care nu
disting cu adevărat aceste două stări
într-un mod semnificativ. Poți auzi ideea
că, dacă măsori unul dintre cei doi qubiți entanglați,
atunci starea celuilalt
WEBVTT
este cumva afectată instantaneu sau că starea celor doi qubiți nu poate fi descrisă separat
sau că cei doi qubiți
cumva păstrează o memorie unul față de celălalt sau chiar că
sunt atașați emoțional în vreun fel.
Dar de ce acele proprietăți
nu sunt valabile pentru această stare?
Acești doi biți sunt strâns conectați, fiecare are o memorie perfectă
a celuilalt în sens literal, dar
nu este o stare entanglată.
Ei bine, o modalitate de a explica ce
face entanglementul special și ce face această stare
foarte diferită de cealaltă este să explici ce
putem face cu entanglementul
sau ce putem observa că se întâmplă
datorită entanglementului, dincolo de deciziile pe care le luăm despre cum ne reprezentăm
cunoștințele folosind vectori.
Toate cele trei exemple
pe care le vom discuta în această lecție au această natură, în sensul că ilustrează
lucruri pe care le putem face cu entanglementul, pe care nu
le putem face cu această stare
sau cu orice stare corelată clasic.
Într-adevăr, este foarte tipic în studiul informației și computației cuantice să privim entanglementul ca pe o resursă
prin care pot fi îndeplinite
diverse sarcini.
Și când facem asta, privim această stare ca reprezentând
o unitate de entanglement.
Ne referim la această unitate de
entanglement ca un e-bit, unde e vine de la
entangled sau entanglement.
Este adevărat că sunt doi qubiți, dar ca o cantitate de
entanglement, este un e-bit.
Poți privi, de asemenea, o pereche
de biți clasici obișnuiți în starea probabilistică corelată de mai devreme ca o resursă care reprezintă
un bit de aleatorie partajată.
Poate fi foarte util în
criptografie să partajezi un bit aleatoriu cu cineva, presupunând
că nimeni altcineva nu știe care este acel bit, astfel încât să
poată fi folosit ca cheie privată
sau ca parte a unei chei private, de exemplu, pentru criptare.
Dar în această lecție, ne vom concentra pe această stare entanglată și
pe lucrurile pe care le putem face cu ea.
Și doar pentru a clarifica terminologia, când spunem că Alice
și Bob partajează un e-bit, ne referim la faptul că
Alice are un qubit numit A,
Bob are un qubit numit B, și împreună perechea A, B
se află în starea Phi plus.
Nu contează ce nume
alegem pentru cei doi qubiți, desigur, am putea
alege nume diferite, dar pe tot parcursul lecției,
vom rămâne la aceste nume
pentru claritate. Primul exemplu al lecției
este quantum teleportation,
la care de acum înainte ne vom referi pur și simplu ca teleportare, pentru concizie.
Teleportarea este un protocol care permite unui expeditor să
transmită informații cuantice unui receptor folosind doar entanglementul
și comunicarea clasică pentru
a realiza acea transmisie.
Nu are absolut nicio legătură cu interpretarea tipică
a cuvântului teleportare din science fiction, care
spune că materia dispare
dintr-un loc și apare în altul.
Quantum teleportation este doar un nume menit să evoce acea imagine sau ca o metaforă, ca să spun așa.
Ceea ce se teleportează este
informația cuantică, nu materia, și asta se întâmplă
printr-o transmisie de informații clasice
împreună cu entanglementul.
Pentru a înțelege exact
cum funcționează teleportarea, este util să începem prin a
pregăti scena, ca să spun așa.
Ce vom face este să ne imaginăm un scenariu care implică Alice și Bob, iar
acel scenariu este următorul:
Alice are un qubit numit Q pe
care ar dori să îl transmită lui Bob, adică vrea ca Bob să dețină în mâinile sale
un qubit care se află exact
în aceeași stare în care se află Q la începutul protocolului.
Cu alte cuvinte, vorbim despre problema fundamentală a
transmiterii informațiilor sau a comunicării.
Avem un expeditor numit Alice
și un receptor numit Bob, iar Alice vrea să trimită
informații cuantice sub forma unui qubit lui Bob.
Există o constrângere, totuși, și anume că Alice nu
poate trimite fizic Q lui Bob, tot ce poate face este să trimită informații clasice lui Bob.
Alice și Bob au, de asemenea,
o resursă suplimentară, și anume că partajează un e-bit.
Acesta este scenariul, este
ușor să ne imaginăm situații în care constrângerea că
Alice nu poate trimite fizic Q
lui Bob este o abstracțiune rezonabilă.
Dacă Alice și Bob s-ar afla
pe continente diferite, de exemplu, sau dacă Alice nu știe
locația exactă a lui Bob, atunci trimiterea fizică a unui qubit
ar fi probabil destul de dificilă.
Dar comunicarea clasică
nu este doar posibilă, ci și destul de ieftină
în acele circumstanțe.
Acum, cineva ar putea întreba dacă este posibil ca Alice și Bob să îndeplinească această sarcină fără a mai fi nevoie de e-bit-ul partajat.
Cu alte cuvinte, există
vreo modalitate de a transmite un qubit folosind doar
comunicarea clasică?
Răspunsul este nu, nu este posibil să transmiți informații cuantice folosind doar comunicarea clasică, și asta nu este prea dificil de demonstrat
folosind câteva noțiuni de bază de
teoria informației cuantice, pe care le vom vedea în
a treia unitate a seriei.
Deocamdată, o modalitate intuitivă
de a gândi la asta este să ne gândim la teorema no-cloning.
WEBVTT
Imaginează-ți că există o modalitate
de a trimite informații cuantice folosind doar comunicarea clasică,
dar comunicarea clasică
poate fi copiată și difuzată cu ușurință, ceea ce înseamnă că
comunicarea clasică
ar putea fi difuzată la doi
receptori, Bob și Charlie, să zicem.
Dacă amândoi ar primi
aceleași informații clasice de la Alice, ar
ajunge amândoi să dețină Q?
Asta ar sugera că am clonat Q, dar știm că este imposibil.
Ca o paranteză, să
observăm că este cu siguranță posibil să descrii
vectori de stare cuantică folosind informații clasice.
Fiecare vector de stare cuantică
pe care îl vei vedea în serie îți este descris
folosind informații clasice transmise oricărui
dispozitiv pe care privești.
În general, am putea imagina
că descriem orice stare în care se află Q folosind biți clasici,
poate cu o anumită precizie,
dar aceasta nu este comunicare cuantică, este doar descrierea
stărilor cuantice ca vectori, și vom reveni la
distincția dintre ele
imediat.
Revenind la scenariu, totuși, și lucrând sub
ipoteza că Alice și Bob partajează un e-bit, vom
vedea că Alice și Bob
au tot ce le trebuie
pentru a îndeplini sarcina, și acesta este ceea ce face protocolul de
quantum teleportation, folosind în mod specific doi biți
de comunicare clasică.
Înainte de a intra în
aceste detalii, totuși, lasă-mă să fac câteva observații rapide
doar pentru a mă asigura că ipotezele sunt clare.
În primul rând, presupunem
că starea lui Q este necunoscută lui Alice și
lui Bob, deci, în particular,
Alice nu poate trimite lui Bob o
descriere a stării Q, deoarece în general nu o cunoaște.
Trebuie, de asemenea, să luăm în considerare posibilitatea că Q este corelat cu alte sisteme, inclusiv posibilitatea
că este entanglat
cu alte sisteme și că
transmiterea acestui qubit lui Bob trebuie să păstreze acele corelații.
În final, am menționat
teorema no-cloning când vorbeam despre
încercarea de a comunica qubiți în mod clasic, dar
există o altă legătură
cu teorema no-cloning, și anume că, dacă Bob
primește transmisia acestui qubit Q de la Alice,
atunci Alice nu mai trebuie să-l aibă
deoarece Q nu poate fi clonat, și acesta este doar un lucru de ținut minte
în timp ce luăm în considerare protocolul de teleportare.
Protocolul de
teleportare poate fi descris într-un mod destul de simplu și direct cu diagrama quantum circuit, după cum poți vedea chiar aici.
Este ușor stilizat în
sensul că depictează separarea dintre partea lui Alice și partea lui Bob, dar altfel, este doar
o diagramă quantum circuit,
tot ce se află deasupra liniei punctate
reprezintă acțiunile lui Alice și tot ce se află dedesubt
reprezintă acțiunile lui Bob.
Timpul curge de la stânga la dreapta ca întotdeauna, și vedem că începem
cu acești doi qubiți aflați în starea Phi plus,
deci acesta este e-bit-ul
cu care Alice și Bob încep.
Putem pune etichete pe qubiți pentru a clarifica care este care, deci acesta este qubit-ul A, iar acesta este qubit-ul
B care formează e-bit-ul,
și acesta este qubit-ul Q pe care
Alice dorește să-l transmită lui Bob.
Aici presupunem că
starea acestui qubit Q este Psi, dar puțin mai târziu vom lua în considerare posibilitatea
că Q este entanglat
cu un alt sistem. Și ceea ce diagrama susține, deoarece am scris psi aici jos,
este că acest circuit
transmite efectiv orice stare psi pe care am avut-o
aici sus la Alice, jos la Bob,
singura comunicare
care traversează
linia dintre Alice și Bob sunt cei doi biți clasici
reprezentați de aceste linii duble chiar aici.
Să micșorăm puțin această
diagramă astfel încât să avem puțin mai mult spațiu și să examinăm
circuitul mai îndeaproape.
Am descris deja
condițiile inițiale, dar doar pentru a recapitula, Alice deține un qubit A
și Bob deține un qubit B,
unde A și B împreună
se află în starea Phi plus, acesta este ceea ce înseamnă să partajezi un e-bit.
Alice mai are și acest qubit Q pe care dorește să-l transmită lui Bob, și luăm în considerare cazul în care Q se află în o stare cuantică arbitrară Psi.
Acum, nu știm nimic
despre cum au intrat Alice și Bob în posesia acestui e-bit.
S-ar putea ca ei să-l
dețină de mult timp, poate l-au creat cândva când se aflau în aceeași locație
și l-au păstrat
pentru această ocazie, dar acele detalii nu sunt relevante aici.
Pașii care urmează, reprezentând
protocolul de teleportare în sine, sunt următori, și doar pentru a fi clar,
aceștia sunt pașii pe care
diagrama îi descrie și îi vom
scrie cu cuvinte pentru a fi clar ce
exprimă diagrama.
Alice efectuează mai întâi o
operație controlled-NOT în care qubit-ul Q pe care
vrea să-l trimită lui Bob este controlul, iar
qubit-ul A este ținta.
Următorul pas este că ea
efectuează o operație Hadamard pe Q, apoi măsoară
cei doi qubiți pe care îi deține,
A și Q cu privire la
măsurători ale bazei standard și fie a minuscula să fie rezultatul măsurătorii qubit-ului A,
WEBVTT
și fie b minuscula să fie rezultatul măsurătorii qubit-ului Q.
Alice trimite apoi
acei doi biți clasici lui Bob, și aceasta este singura comunicare implicată în acest protocol, indicată în diagramă
de faptul că acești doi
biți traversează linia punctată dintre Alice și Bob,
pe care o poți considera ca reprezentând orice
distanță îi separă.
După ce Bob primește biții
a și b, face două lucruri.
Mai întâi, dacă a este egal cu unu, atunci efectuează o operație X,
sau, cu alte cuvinte, un NOT gate pe qubit-ul B al lui,
și altfel, dacă a este egal cu zero, atunci nu face asta.
Și în mod similar,
dacă b este egal cu unu, atunci Bob efectuează o operație Z
sau un Z-gate sau o inversare de fază
tot pe qubit-ul b și, ca
înainte, dacă b este egal cu zero, atunci nu face asta.
Toate acestea sunt indicate în figură unde avem aceste gate-uri controlled-X
și controlled-Z în care controalele sunt
cei doi biți clasici.
Nu trebuie să te gândești la aceste gate-uri ca la gate-uri de control
dacă nu vrei, acesta este doar un mod convenabil
de a exprima ceea ce vrem
sub forma unei diagrame circuit. Ideea este că Bob aplică
un X-gate qubit-ului b dacă a este egal cu unu și
apoi aplică un Z-gate
qubit-ului b dacă B este egal cu unu.
Și pentru comoditate ulterioară, putem scrie explicit
operația combinată pe care Bob o efectuează pe qubit-ul b al lui,
în funcție de biții clasici
pe care Alice îi trimite.
Acesta este, deci, protocolul de teleportare, este destul de simplu de fapt, faptul că funcționează efectiv este o altă chestiune,
și deși analiza
nu este atât de complicată,
nu trebuie să simți că îți scapă ceva dacă nu înțelegi imediat de ce funcționează.
De aceea trebuie să
parcurgem o analiză și asta vom face în continuare.
Pentru a analiza protocolul de teleportare, vom parcurge câte un pas la un moment pentru a vedea care sunt stările
celor trei qubiți la diferite momente în timp.
Vom lua în considerare mai întâi
cazul în care qubit-ul de sus se află în starea AlphaZero plus beta unu, unde alpha și beta
sunt numere complexe oarecare
care fac ca acest vector
să fie un vector unitar.
Acesta este qubit-ul Q pe care
Alice încearcă să-l transmită, dar nu prea contează
cum îl numim în acest moment.
Puțin mai târziu, vom
analiza situația în care acest qubit este
entanglat cu un alt sistem, dar acesta este un bun punct de pornire pentru a menține lucrurile simple
și pentru a vedea cum funcționează analiza
ceva mai clar.
Dacă luăm în considerare starea
celor trei qubiți împreună la început, vedem
că această stare are forma pe care o poți vedea chiar aici.
Primii doi qubiți se află
în starea Phi plus, cel de-al treilea qubit este cel de sus
conform convenției
pentru ordonarea qubiților pe care
am descris-o în lecția anterioară, și deci calculăm produsul tensorial pentru a obține starea
celor trei qubiți împreună.
Putem extinde această expresie
substituind mai întâi definiția stării Phi plus și apoi calculând produsul tensorial
și obținem starea
pe care o poți vedea chiar aici.
Nu este întotdeauna cea mai bună
strategie, apropo, să extinzi complet
un vector de acest fel, este în general o idee bună să aștepți până
când ai un motiv întemeiat să faci asta.
Dar aici avem un motiv, care este că am vrea
să calculăm acțiunea acestui gate controlled NOT și, scriind starea în această formă,
putem face asta foarte ușor.
Și, în particular, aceasta este
starea celor trei qubiți după ce gate-ul controlled NOT este aplicat.
Cel de-al treilea qubit este qubit-ul de control deoarece este cel care se
află deasupra prin convenția noastră, iar cel de-al doilea qubit,
care este cel din mijloc,
este ținta, deci operăm
pe ket-uri în consecință: dacă al treilea bit este
zero, nu se întâmplă nimic,
iar dacă al treilea bit este unu,
atunci inversăm al doilea bit.
Apoi efectuăm gate-ul Hadamard
pe cel de-al treilea qubit, putem scrie vectorul rezultat, după cum poți vedea
chiar aici substituind
stările plus și minus pentru stările zero și unu.
Și dacă vrem să avem suficient
spațiu pentru a extinde aceasta, va trebui să
o micșorăm puțin și acum, substituind stările
plus și minus
cu definițiile lor,
aducând rădăcina pătrată din doi la numitor, obținem starea pe care o poți vedea chiar aici.
Și extinzând aceea, obținem starea pe care o poți vedea chiar aici.
Aceasta este, deci, starea celor trei qubiți după ce Alice efectuează cele două operații ale sale.
Alice măsoară apoi
și dacă vrem să analizăm măsurătorile, ceea ce facem este să izolăm vectorii bazei standard
pentru sistemele care sunt măsurate
exact cum am discutat în lecția a doua, și dacă facem asta în acest caz particular, iată ce obținem.
Și dacă te uiți la acea
expresie pentru un moment, ar putea părea puțin ciudată deoarece acum pare că primul qubit,
care este qubit-ul de jos,
depinde cumva de alpha și beta, chiar dacă
la acest punct nu a existat nicio comunicare dincolo de linia punctată,
WEBVTT
dar aceasta este doar o iluzie. Ține minte că scalarele circulă
liber prin produsele tensoriale, deci nu există niciun sens
în care alpha și beta
sunt asociate cu primul qubit.
Tot ce am făcut de fapt
este să folosim paranteze în concordanță cu
multiliniaritatea produselor tensoriale.
În orice caz, aceasta este forma de care avem nevoie pentru a vedea ce face măsurătoarea, și putem observa deja un lucru
interesant
și anume că probabilitățile celor patru rezultate posibile ale măsurătorii sunt întotdeauna uniforme.
Probabilitatea de a măsura fiecare
pereche de rezultate ale măsurătorii este un sfert, deci, în particular,
nu există nicio dependență
față de alpha și beta.
Putem vedea asta în fiecare caz calculând norma euclidiană la pătrat a
oricărui vector calculat ca produs tensorial cu vectorul bazei standard pe care l-am izolat,
și în fiecare caz obținem un sfert, care se obține prin ridicarea la pătrat a lui una peste doi multiplicat cu valoarea absolută la pătrat a lui alpha
plus valoarea absolută
la pătrat a lui beta, care este unu, și deci obținem un sfert în fiecare caz.
Este destul de important,
de fapt, că probabilitățile acestor rezultate diferite nu depind în niciun fel de qubit-ul pe care
Alice vrea să-l transmită.
Nu am putea accepta ca o stare arbitrară să intre sus și să iasă jos, și totuși o măsurătoare să fi dezvăluit
informații despre acea stare.
Dacă vrei să obții informații despre o stare cuantică arbitrară, va trebui să perturbezi
acea stare în general.
Iată un tabel care descrie nu doar probabilitățile
rezultatelor diferite, ci și starea
celor trei qubiți împreună
condiționată de fiecare rezultat posibil
al măsurătorii.
Obținem asta normalizând vectorii calculați ca produs tensorial cu diferitele
stări ale bazei standard, ceea ce este ușor în acest caz,
eliminăm pur și simplu factorul de una peste doi pentru a obține un vector unitar.
Deci, ceea ce avem imediat
după ce Alice măsoară este că Alice are doi biți aleatori uniformi și atât.
În particular, ea nu mai
are starea originală și nu are nicio
informație despre ea, are doar biți aleatori.
Starea lui Bob acum
depinde de alpha și beta, precum și de rezultatele măsurătorii.
Dacă ne imaginăm momentan
că Alice nu a trimis încă rezultatele măsurătorii
astfel încât Bob să nu știe care sunt rezultatele măsurătorii,
el nu ar putea
obține nicio informație despre alpha și beta
măsurând qubit-ul lui.
Aceste patru posibilități
pe care le avem chiar aici sunt suficient de amestecate pentru a garanta că nicio informație
despre alpha și beta
nu ar putea fi vreodată obținută
printr-o măsurătoare. Asta trebuie să fie adevărat la nivel intuitiv, deoarece altfel am avea
comunicare mai rapidă decât lumina.
Alice cu siguranță nu
poate transmite informații lui Bob fără a trimite nimic, dar desigur Alice trimite rezultatele măsurătorii
lui Bob, deci să extindem tabelul pentru a vedea ce se întâmplă când
Bob efectuează operațiile sale.
În această coloană chiar aici, avem diferitele operații pe care Bob le efectuează efectiv pentru fiecare dintre rezultatele posibile
ale măsurătorilor
cum am observat înainte,
și dacă parcurgem unul câte unul și aplicăm acea
operație qubit-ului lui Bob, care este primul, B,
vedem că obținem același
rezultat în toate cele patru cazuri și acel rezultat este starea originală.
Deci, starea originală a qubit-ului Q a fost teleportată cu succes în B.
Dacă Bob vrea să-și redenumească qubit-ul și să îl numească Q în acest moment, este binevenite să facă asta, dar ideea este că acum
el deține starea originală
pe care o avea Alice și, desigur, prin necesitate, Alice nu o mai are.
Observă, de asemenea, că e-bit-ul
a fost efectiv consumat prin acest proces,
teleportarea are un cost
și costul este un e-bit și doi biți clasici de comunicare, și când protocolul se
termină, e-bit-ul este epuizat.
Am stabilit acum că
protocolul de teleportare funcționează corect sub ipoteza că qubit-ul de sus se află în o stare cuantică
de forma alpha ori ket
zero plus beta ori ket unu.
Dar ce se întâmplă dacă
qubit-ul de sus este entanglat cu un alt sistem, cum ar fi
unul dintre qubiții noștri suplimentari
cum avem pe ecran? Am putea dori să folosim teleportarea
în astfel de circumstanțe.
Poate Alice și Bob plănuiesc de fapt
să efectueze teleportarea de 100 de ori astfel încât Alice să poată transmite
un registru cuantic de 100 de qubiți
lui Bob, câte un qubit pe rând.
Sau poate acești qubiți suplimentari
nici măcar nu sunt în posesia lui Alice
și altcineva îi deține, poate Alice nici măcar
nu știe că există.
Întrebarea este, funcționează
teleportarea în continuare chiar dacă qubit-ul teleportat este entanglat cu un alt sistem?
Aici, starea qubit-ului Q împreună cu
sistemul suplimentar pe care îl luăm în considerare este exprimată după cum poți vedea chiar sus
unde gamma zero și
gamma unu sunt vectori unitari reprezentând stări cuantice
ale acestui sistem suplimentar.
Putem scrie întotdeauna o stare arbitrară a sistemului combinat în acest fel.
Nu avem de fapt nevoie de alpha și beta,
dar dacă le includem,
putem lua gamma zero și gamma unu ca vectori unitari
și asta va face
legătura cu cazul mai simplu pe care l-am considerat deja mai transparentă.
WEBVTT
Putem parcurge o
analiză similară cu cea pe care am parcurs-o deja, dar în care urmărim de asemenea
acest sistem suplimentar.
Este puțin mai complicat deoarece avem sistemul suplimentar, dar
ideea este exact aceeași, iată un rezumat foarte rapid.
Aceasta este starea inițială, iată starea după
gate-ul controlled NOT,
și iată starea după
operația Hadamard.
Dacă extindem acestea,
putem exprima acea stare după cum poți vedea chiar aici,
aceasta este starea imediat
înainte de măsurătorile lui Alice, și dacă parcurgem
posibilitățile exact ca înainte
și luăm în considerare ce
se întâmplă când Bob aplică orice operație pe care trebuie să o aplice,
constatăm că într-adevăr
starea corectă iese și protocolul funcționează conform așteptărilor.
În acest tabel, apropo, folosim litera R pentru a
ne referi la acest sistem suplimentar, și poți vedea că folosim un truc destul de simplu,
care este să decidem că preferăm, cel puțin momentan, să ordonăm
sistemele ca B, R, A, Q
deoarece este mai convenabil pentru a scrie stările chiar aici.
Conform diagramei, sistemele ar trebui să fie
ordonate ca B, A, Q, R,
dar atâta timp cât clarificăm, putem alege o
ordonare diferită care este mai convenabilă.
Pe scurt, tot ce se întâmplă în această analiză este
același lucru ca în analiza mai simplă,
dar se întâmplă să avem
acești vectori suplimentari, gamma zero și gamma unu
care vin practic ca pasageri.
Avem întotdeauna gamma zero
când există un factor de alpha și gamma unu când
există un factor de beta și la final,
totul funcționează corect.
Aceasta nu este de fapt deloc surprinzătoare, avem un proces fizic care acționează ca operația identitate
pe un qubit
în o stare cuantică arbitrară, și există un singur
mod în care asta se poate întâmpla și acela este că operația
este operația identitate.
Aceasta este puțin mai ușor de explicat folosind formularea generală
a informației cuantice, dar ideea este că, prin liniaritate,
nu era de fapt nevoie să parcurgem această analiză suplimentară.
Odată ce știm că
teleportarea funcționează corect pentru un singur qubit izolat, putem concluziona că există
un singur lucru posibil
care poate descrie ce face protocolul, și anume că implementează
operația identitate în care un qubit intră chiar aici
și iese chiar aici, funcționând efectiv ca un canal cuantic perfect
fără zgomot.
Câteva observații rapide
despre teleportare înainte de a trece la
al doilea exemplu al lecției, care este superdense coding.
În primul rând, cred că este important să clarificăm că teleportarea nu este o aplicație a informației cuantice, este un protocol
și mai specific este un
protocol pentru realizarea comunicării cuantice.
Pentru ca teleportarea
pe care am descris-o să fie utilă, trebuie să existe un motiv pentru efectuarea comunicării cuantice.
În al doilea rând, este rezonabil să speculăm că teleportarea ar putea, într-o zi, deveni o modalitate standard
de a comunica informații cuantice, și mai specific un proces cunoscut sub numele de entanglement distillation
ar putea fi utilizat potențial
ca o modalitate de a comunica qubiți în mod fiabil. Dacă Alice și Bob știu că vor
comunica informații cuantice sau au nevoie să comunice
informații cuantice, atunci acest proces de entanglement distillation
ar putea fi folosit pentru a converti un număr mai mare de e-biți zgomotoși
într-un număr mai mic
de e-biți de înaltă calitate care ar putea fi folosiți pentru teleportare fără zgomot sau aproape fără zgomot.
Ideea este că procesul
de entanglement distillation nu este la fel de delicat în unele sensuri, putem accepta pierderi și
dacă nu funcționează,
putem încerca din nou, în timp ce qubiții efectivi pe care
am dori să îi comunicăm ar putea fi considerați mult mai prețioși.
Desigur, toate acestea sunt speculații, dar ideea este că nu este dificil să ipotezăm situații
în care teleportarea
ar putea fi o modalitate foarte practică
de a comunica qubiți.
Și ultima observație
privind teleportarea este că ideea din spatele teleportării și modul în care funcționează
este destul de fundamentală
în informația și computația cuantică, teleportarea este cu adevărat o piatră de temelie a teoriei
informației cuantice, iar variațiile
pe această idee apar și ele des,
iată un exemplu: există propuneri pentru
implementarea diferitelor quantum gate-uri
folosind teleportarea, dar
unde se aleg stări inițiale și măsurători diferite, astfel încât rezultatul
să fie aplicarea unei operații alese
mai degrabă decât comunicarea.
Următorul exemplu este superdense coding.
La fel ca quantum teleportation,
superdense coding este un protocol și ceea ce realizează este complementar teleportării.
În timp ce teleportarea permite
transmiterea unui qubit folosind un e-bit și doi
biți clasici de comunicare,
superdense coding permite
transmiterea a doi biți clasici folosind
un e-bit și un qubit de comunicare cuantică.
Deci, pe scurt, superdense coding permite transmiterea
informațiilor clasice și motivul pentru care se numește superdense coding
WEBVTT
este că permite ca doi
biți clasici de comunicare să fie împachetați într-un singur qubit,
dar trebuie să consumăm un
e-bit pentru a realiza asta.
Iată o explicație mai precisă
a configurației.
Din nou, avem Alice și Bob, unde Alice este expeditorul
și Bob este receptorul, și de data aceasta Alice are doi biți clasici
pe care vrea să îi trimită lui Bob.
Alice poate trimite lui Bob un singur qubit, iar Alice și Bob partajează
un e-bit pe care îl pot folosi pentru a-i ajuta să-și îndeplinească sarcina,
care este ca Bob să primească
cei doi biți clasici.
Acum, există un sens în care această sarcină poate părea mai puțin interesantă decât sarcina pe care
o îndeplinește teleportarea,
în special dacă considerăm
că trimiterea de qubiți este semnificativ mai
dificilă sau mai solicitantă decât trimiterea de biți clasici,
ceea ce este un punct de vedere destul de rezonabil, dar este cu siguranță interesant că este posibil să faci asta.
Un motiv pentru care este interesant
este că este de fapt imposibil să îndeplinești
această sarcină de a transmite doi biți clasici de informație
folosind un singur qubit fără
a face uz de e-bit.
Știm asta datorită unui teorema celebru cunoscut sub numele de teorema lui Holevo.
Teorema lui Holevo este
mai generală decât atât, și enunțul precis
al teoremei lui Holevo este puțin tehnic și necesită câteva explicații,
dar o implicație a acesteia
este că nu poți transmite niciun număr de biți clasici
de comunicare folosind mai puțini qubiți de
comunicare cuantică în mod exclusiv.
Dacă vrei să transmiți în mod fiabil doi biți clasici de
informație folosind qubiți și nu ai
un e-bit la dispoziție,
va trebui să trimiți doi qubiți, deci poate fel la fel de bine să stochezi biții pe care vrei să îi transmiți în ei.
Un alt motiv pentru care superdense
coding este interesant este datorită strânsei
relații complementare pe care o are cu teleportarea, și
vom reveni la asta
puțin mai târziu. Iată o descriere prin quantum circuit a protocolului de superdense coding.
Pentru acesta, nu voi
enumera toți pașii, ci ne vom limita la descrierea prin diagramă circuit.
După cum poți vedea, avem din nou
Alice și Bob, unde Alice este sus
și Bob este jos.
Iată e-bit-ul care este
partajat inițial între Alice și Bob, care a fost
stabilit cumva înainte de rularea protocolului.
Alice are doi biți clasici, A și B, pe care îi poți vedea sus
și prin protocolul pe care circuitul îl descrie,
acești doi biți clasici
vor ajunge în mâinile lui Bob.
Există un singur qubit
care traversează linia dintre Alice și Bob, și desigur nu există
niciun bit clasic trimis,
transmiterea
celor doi biți clasici este scopul protocolului.
Vei observa, de asemenea, că are
exact aceleași componente care sunt folosite în teleportare: avem un gate controlled NOT,
un gate Hadamard,
și un Z și un X-gate
controlate de biți clasici.
Sunt aranjate diferit, totuși, deci să trecem la
analiză pentru a vedea cum funcționează.
Pentru a analiza cum funcționează superdense coding, să începem prin a scrie
baza Bell, care este foarte mult în
inima analizei.
Ce vom face este
să analizăm mai întâi efectul pe care acțiunile lui Alice
îl au asupra stării Phi plus, și vom vedea că Alice transformă aceasta
stare Phi plus în una
din cele patru stări Bell, în funcție de biții
pe care vrea să îi trimită.
Deci, să scriem un tabel pentru a ține
evidența a ceea ce se întâmplă.
În primul rând, dacă A și B sunt ambele zero, atunci nici Z-gate-ul, nici
X-gate-ul nu se aplică, deci acțiunile lui Alice nu fac nimic,
ceea ce înseamnă că Phi
plus se mapează la Phi plus.
Putem exprima asta și ca o ecuație ca cea pe care o poți vedea chiar aici,
nimic nu se întâmplă cu qubit-ul lui Alice și nimic nu se întâmplă cu qubit-ul lui Bob
și a nu face nimic este reprezentat
de matricea identitate.
Acum, ce se întâmplă dacă A este egal cu zero și B este egal cu unu?
Ei bine, deoarece B este egal cu unu, aplicăm Z-gate-ul și
nu aplicăm X-gate-ul deoarece A este egal cu zero
și vedem că efectul general este că Alice efectuează un Z-gate.
Alice este la dreapta
deoarece este sus, deși nu ar
conta în mod real în acest caz particular, efectul este că
starea Phi plus
se mapează la Phi minus, ceea ce poți observa
din aceste expresii dacă îți amintești cum funcționează un Z-gate.
Deci, putem adăuga acesta în tabelul nostru, mai sunt două cazuri de parcurs: dacă A este egal cu unu
și B este egal cu zero,
atunci Alice efectuează un
X-gate care transformă Phi plus în Chi plus, și dacă A este egal cu unu
și B este egal cu unu,
atunci Alice efectuează Z, apoi
X și obținem Chi minus.
Deci, tabelul nostru ne spune ce se întâmplă în cele patru cazuri posibile și anume că Alice alege efectiv care una
WEBVTT
dintre cele patru stări Bell dorește
să o partajeze cu Bob, și are libertatea de a alege acționând doar pe qubit-ul ei
și aceasta este un aspect destul de interesant
al entanglementului.
Alice trimite apoi qubit-ul ei
lui Bob, în acest moment, Bob deține una din cele patru stări Bell și trebuie doar să
afle care este aceea
pentru a recupera biții.
Și putem verifica că
într-adevăr un gate controlled NOT urmat de un gate Hadamard
cum avem în diagramă face lucrul corect.
Nu voi parcurge în detaliu, dar dacă alegi să faci asta, vei constata că efectul este
cel pe care îl poți vedea aici în tabel.
O modalitate de a verifica
este pur și simplu să calculezi. Alternativ, putem recunoaște că am parcurs deja asta în sens invers
în lecția anterioară. În lecția anterioară am
avut mai întâi gate-ul Hadamard și al doilea gate-ul controlled NOT
și am văzut că acel circuit
mapa stările bazei standard la stările Bell cu un semn minus enervant în unul dintre cazuri.
Când inversăm ordinea gate-urilor și luăm în considerare faptul
că ambele aceste gate-uri sunt propriile lor inverse,
obținem inversul,
deci ce avem în acest
caz este că acțiunea merge în direcția opusă
și semnul minus poate alege pe care
parte vrea să fie,
dar altfel, este acolo unde îi este locul, și în acest punct este
imediat evident că măsurătoarea dezvăluie valorile corecte,
semnul minus de aici nu ne deranjează deoarece unul apare cu
probabilitatea unu în acest caz, și aceasta este toată analiza.
Pe scurt, Alice alege o stare Bell și Bob determină care este.
Câteva observații scurte
despre superdense coding înainte de a continua: în primul rând, ar trebui să recunoaștem
că superdense coding
probabil nu va fi
util sau practic în niciun sens ca mijloc de
transmitere a informațiilor clasice.
Comunicarea clasică
este foarte ieftină, iar trimiterea fizică a qubiților este solicitantă, ca să spunem cel mai ușor,
și atâta timp cât aceasta este situația, nu ne-am aștepta la niciun
avantaj practic din superdense coding.
Dar faptul că probabil nu va fi
practic nu înseamnă că superdense
coding nu este interesant.
Este de fapt foarte interesant, în primul rând, ideea de bază este
cu adevărat destul de fundamentală,
și când mă refer la ideea de bază, mă refer la ideea că, dacă Alice
partajează o stare Bell cu Bob,
atunci ea poate alege să schimbe acea stare în orice altă stare Bell
pe care o alege, singură, fără
ajutorul lui Bob.
Acesta este un exemplu specific
care privește stările Bell, dar există o idee de bază mai generală care privește libertatea pe care un jucător
o are de a transforma o stare entanglată partajată cu un alt jucător, și înțelegerea exactă
a ceea ce este acea libertate
este un pas important în înțelegerea informației cuantice și vom vedea exact cum să descriem acea libertate în termeni simpli
și eleganți în
a treia unitate a seriei.
Superdense coding oferă, de asemenea,
un exemplu concret a ceea ce poți face cu entanglementul, care este să permiți transmiterea a doi biți clasici
prin trimiterea unui singur qubit. Cum am menționat deja, acest lucru
nu este posibil, conform teoremei lui Holevo, fără entanglement.
Putem lua în considerare și teleportarea și superdense coding împreună, și vedem că ele
stabilesc o echivalență
între un qubit de comunicare cuantică și doi biți de comunicare clasică.
Atâta timp cât ești dispus
să cheltuiești un e-bit, poți converti efectiv
unul în celălalt.
Teleportarea permite
comunicarea unui qubit folosind doi biți clasici de comunicare, iar superdense coding merge în sens invers
și permite doi biți clasici
de comunicare folosind un qubit de comunicare cuantică.
Fără a cheltui e-bit-ul, totuși, nu poți transforma
niciunul în celălalt, entanglementul este cel care
face asta posibil.
Al treilea și ultimul exemplu
pe care îl vom aborda în această lecție nu este un protocol, ci un
joc cunoscut sub numele de jocul CHSH.
Când vorbim despre un joc în acest context, nu vorbim despre ceva menit să fie
jucat de plăcere sau pentru competiție,
ci mai degrabă o abstracțiune matematică în sensul teoriei jocurilor, de exemplu.
Abstracțiunile matematice ale jocurilor sunt studiate foarte frecvent în
economie și informatică, de exemplu, și există
destul de multă valoare
în abstracțiune, deci jocurile nu sunt toate distractive
în jocuri, se pare,
deși este distractiv să te gândești la ele.
În acest caz particular, ceea ce avem este în esență
un experiment de gândire care poate fi descris într-un mod
destul de intuitiv ca un joc.
Literele CHSH se referă la autori, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony și Richard Holt, ai unui articol din 1969
în care exemplul
a fost descris pentru prima dată. De fapt, ei nu l-au descris
ca pe un joc, și este destul de obișnuit
să ne referim la acest exemplu
nu ca la jocul CHSH, ci
mai degrabă ca la inegalitatea CHSH.
Pentru un informatician ca mine, totuși, este foarte natural
să îl descriu ca pe un joc.
Am sugerat deja că
abstracțiunile matematice ale jocurilor sunt atât importante, cât și utile și există multe categorii diferite de jocuri
WEBVTT
care pot fi luate în considerare. Jocul CHSH este un
exemplu al unei clase de jocuri numite jocuri non-locale.
Iată configurația generală
pentru un joc non-local.
Avem doi jucători, Alice și Bob, care cooperează ca o echipă, deci câștigă împreună
sau pierd împreună.
Asta înseamnă că nu au niciun
stimulent să acționeze egoist, deci este practic extrema opusă față de jocurile cu sumă zero,
care sunt pur competitive, în timp ce jocul de față este pur cooperativ.
Există o a treia entitate numită arbitrul.
Arbitrul nu este un jucător în joc, ci mai degrabă arbitrul
conduce jocul, și de fapt poți să te gândești la specificația
unei anumite instanțe
a unui joc non-local și la specificarea unui
arbitru ca fiind echivalente.
Există o constrângere extrem de importantă impusă lui Alice și Bob, care este că odată ce jocul începe, le este interzis să comunice unul cu celălalt.
Pot conveni dinainte asupra
oricărei strategii pe care o aleg, dar nicio comunicare
nu este permisă între ei în timpul jocului în sine.
Dacă vrei, poți imagina
jocul desfășurându-se într-o facilitate securizată de un anumit fel, ca și cum arbitrul joacă
rolul unui detectiv
și Alice și Bob sunt suspecți situați în camere diferite
la o secție de poliție, dar o altă modalitate de
a gândi la configurație
este că Alice și Bob sunt
separați de o distanță vastă și comunicarea este interzisă deoarece viteza luminii
nu permite comunicarea
să se întâmple suficient de rapid. Dacă Alice încearcă să trimită un
mesaj lui Bob, de exemplu, jocul se va fi terminat până
când Bob îl primește.
Modul în care funcționează un joc
non-local este că mai întâi, arbitrul pune o întrebare atât
lui Alice, cât și lui Bob.
Întrebarea lui Alice este etichetată X, iar întrebarea lui Bob este etichetată Y.
În general, poți gândi X și Y ca stări clasice
din orice stări clasice care îți plac, iar în
cazul specific al jocului CHSH,
X și Y sunt biți.
Alice și Bob trebuie să ofere atunci răspunsuri, răspunsul lui Alice este etichetat A,
iar răspunsul lui Bob este etichetat B,
și din nou, aceste răspunsuri pot fi privite ca stări clasice în general și la fel ca întrebările, vor fi biți în jocul CHSH.
În acest moment,
arbitrul ia o decizie, Alice și Bob câștigă sau pierd în funcție de dacă
perechea de răspunsuri A, B
este considerată corectă pentru
perechea de întrebări X, Y pe care arbitrul le-a pus, și voi spune ceva mai mult
despre asta într-un moment.
Mai întâi, să aruncăm o
privire mai atentă la arbitru pentru a înțelege ce
este potențial dificil pentru Alice și Bob într-un joc non-local.
Ceea ce face un joc
non-local potențial dificil este că arbitrul poate folosi aleatorie pentru a alege întrebările X și Y.
Asta înseamnă că Alice
și Bob au incertitudine, nu știu dinainte ce întrebare vor fi întrebați, și poate mai important,
nu știu ce întrebare
a primit celălalt și tocmai acea incertitudine
împreună cu faptul că nu pot comunica
prezintă provocarea.
Deci, este similar cu situația în care un detectiv
interoghează doi suspecți în camere diferite: dacă
suspecții nu știu
ce întrebări i se pun celuilalt, este mult mai greu, dacă sunt vinovați, să-și mențină povestea consistentă.
Acum, am menționat cu puțin timp în urmă că arbitrul ia o hotărâre
conform căreia Alice și Bob au răspuns fie
corect, fie incorect
în funcție de întrebările
care li s-au pus.
Se presupune că
această hotărâre este luată conform unei reguli fixe și poți lua în considerare orice regulă dorești,
dar indiferent care este,
se presupune că Alice
și Bob cunosc regula, deci cel puțin au o șansă
de a răspunde corect.
Vom arunca o privire la
regula pentru jocul CHSH într-un moment, dar am putea
lua în considerare o regulă diferită și am avea un exemplu diferit al unui joc non-local.
Unele jocuri non-locale sunt interesante și de fapt unele sunt destul de fascinante și misterioase până în ziua de azi, iar
altele nu sunt atât de interesante,
aceasta este pur și simplu natura
modelului jocului non-local.
Oricum, acestea sunt cele două lucruri diferite necesare pentru a descrie un arbitru: cum exact sunt alese întrebările
și care perechi de răspunsuri sunt corecte pentru fiecare pereche posibilă de întrebări.
Dacă avem o descriere
a acelor două lucruri, atunci avem o descriere pentru arbitru și asta descrie efectiv
o instanță a unui joc non-local.
Acum, să aruncăm o privire la
jocul CHSH în mod specific.
Modul în care jocul este
definit sau, în mod echivalent, cum este definit arbitrul, este după cum urmează:
în primul rând, cum am menționat deja, întrebările și răspunsurile sunt toți biți, deci arbitrul trimite un bit X
lui Alice și un bit Y lui Bob,
și fiecare răspunde cu un bit. Alice răspunde cu A
și Bob răspunde cu B.
Modul în care arbitrul alege
ce întrebări să pună este simplu: le alege
uniform la întâmplare,
deci, perechea de întrebări X, Y este egal de probabil să fie oricare
din cele patru posibilități: zero, zero; zero, unu;
unu, zero; și unu, unu.
În final, regula care
determină care răspunsuri câștigă și care pierd este
că o pereche de răspunsuri A, B este corectă pentru perechea de întrebări X, Y
WEBVTT
dacă și numai dacă sau-ul exclusiv al lui A și B este egal cu și-ul logic al lui X și Y.
Asta poate fi puțin mai ușor de digerat dacă exprimăm aceste condiții
sub forma unui tabel, după cum poți vedea chiar aici.
În prima coloană, avem cele patru perechi posibile de întrebări, iar în a doua coloană avem condițiile pentru A și B
care sunt necesare pentru
ca Alice și Bob să câștige.
În primele trei cazuri,
și-ul lui A și Y este zero, deci sau-ul exclusiv trebuie să fie egal cu zero
pentru ca ei să câștige,
și asta este același lucru cu a spune că A și B trebuie să fie egali, deoarece A și B sunt biți,
iar în al patrulea caz,
și-ul lui X și Y este egal
cu unu și deci sau-ul exclusiv al lui A și B trebuie să fie egal cu unu pentru ca Alice și Bob să câștige
și asta este același lucru
cu a spune că A și B trebuie să fie diferiți.
Acesta este, deci, jocul CHSH, și acum putem gândi la
diferite strategii posibile pentru Alice și Bob și cât de bine se pot descurca în acest joc.
Să începem prin a gândi la
strategii deterministe, unde răspunsul A al lui Alice este o
funcție a întrebării X pe care o primește, și
în mod similar, răspunsul B al lui Bob
este o funcție a
întrebării Y pe care o primește.
Și, după cum se dovedește, nicio
strategie deterministă nu poate câștiga de fiecare dată.
O modalitate de a raționa asta este
pur și simplu să parcurgi una câte una toate strategiile
deterministe posibile și să verifici că fiecare pierde
pentru cel puțin una din cele patru
perechi posibile de întrebări.
Alice și Bob au fiecare
patru funcții posibile de ales, am văzut
acele patru funcții în lecția întâi, deci există 16 posibilități
de verificat în total.
O altă modalitate de a vedea asta este să
gândim la ecuațiile de pe ecran: gândim
la strategii deterministe
unde A și B sunt funcții
de X și respectiv Y.
Deci, de exemplu, A de zero
reprezintă răspunsul lui Alice când întrebarea X este egală cu zero, iar a de unu reprezintă răspunsul lui Alice
când întrebarea X este egală cu unu.
Acestea sunt cele patru ecuații
care trebuie să fie adevărate pentru ca
condițiile de câștig să fie îndeplinite în fiecare din cele patru cazuri.
De exemplu, dacă X este egal cu
zero și Y este egal cu zero, atunci sau-ul exclusiv al lui A
și B trebuie să fie egal cu zero,
pe când în cazul în care X este egal cu unu și Y este egal cu unu,
sau-ul exclusiv al lui A și B trebuie să fie egal cu unu.
O modalitate prin care putem vedea că
nu există nicio posibilitate de a alege funcțiile A și B astfel încât
toate aceste ecuații să fie adevărate, este pur și simplu să luăm sau-ul exclusiv al tuturor ecuațiilor.
Sau-ul exclusiv al oricărei
valori binare cu ea însăși este egal cu zero, și deci urmează că or-ul exclusiv al
membrilor stângi
este egal cu zero, asta
deoarece avem două instanțe de a zero, două instanțe de a unu,
două instanțe de B zero
și două instanțe de B unu.
Deci, aplicând xor pe toate
obținem răspunsul final de zero, dar dacă luăm or-ul exclusiv al membrilor drepți ai ecuațiilor,
obținem unu, nu zero. Deci cele patru ecuații
nu pot fi toate adevărate în același timp, cel puțin una trebuie să fie falsă
și asta va duce la o
înfrângere pentru Alice și Bob în cel puțin unul din cele patru cazuri.
Și deci urmează, deoarece arbitrul alege întrebările
uniform, că probabilitatea ca Alice și Bob să câștige
folosind o strategie deterministă
este cel mult trei sferturi sau 75%.
Faptul că Alice și Bob pot câștiga cu probabilitate trei sferturi este de fapt destul de ușor de văzut,
dacă Alice și Bob răspund ambii cu zero tot
timpul, de exemplu,
vor fi corecți trei
din patru ori.
Deci Alice și Bob nu pot
face mai bine decât să câștige 75% din timp folosind o
strategie deterministă.
Dar ce este cu o strategie probabilistică?
Ei bine, se dovedește că folosirea
unei strategii probabilistice nu îi ajută deloc, deoarece fiecare
strategie probabilistică
poate fi privită alternativ
ca o selecție aleatorie a unei strategii deterministe, la fel cum operațiile probabilistice pot fi privite
ca selecții aleatoare de
operații deterministe, cum am văzut în prima lecție.
Media nu este niciodată
mai mare decât maximul, deci urmează că o
strategie probabilistică nu oferă niciun avantaj
în ceea ce privește câștigul
față de o strategie deterministă. Aceasta include chiar și posibilitatea că alegerile aleatoare ale lui Alice și Bob sunt corelate.
Deci, concluzia este că câștigul cu probabilitate trei sferturi este cel mai bun pe care Alice
și Bob îl pot obține folosind orice strategie clasică,
indiferent dacă este deterministă
sau probabilistică.
Întrebarea firească de pus la acest punct este dacă Alice și Bob pot face mai bine folosind o strategie cuantică,
și în particular
dacă partajează o stare cuantică entanglată pe care ar fi putut-o prepara
înainte de a juca jocul, poate asta îi ajuta?
Răspunsul este da, poate, și acesta este scopul exemplului și de aceea este atât de interesant.
Deci să vedem exact cum
Alice și Bob pot face mai bine în acest joc folosind entanglementul.
WEBVTT
Primul lucru pe care trebuie să îl facem este să definim un vector de stare cuantică Chi
theta pentru fiecare unghi theta, după cum poți vedea pe ecran.
Deci, Chi theta este egal cu
cosinus theta ori ket zero plus sinus theta ori ket
unu, și apropo,
ne gândim la
unghiuri în termeni de radiani.
Deci, de exemplu, iată vectorul pe care îl obținem când theta este egal cu pi peste
patru, adică 45 de grade.
Cosinusul lui pi peste patru
și sinusul lui pi peste patru sunt ambele egale cu unu peste
rădăcina pătrată din doi, deci acesta este doar un alt
nume pentru starea plus.
Iată un alt exemplu când theta este egal cu trei ori pi peste opt, și în caz că nu
cunoști sinusul
și cosinusul de trei ori pi peste opt din memorie,
iată un tabel cu sinusurile și cosinusurile de care avem de fapt nevoie
pe parcursul acestui exemplu
și include pe cele de care avem nevoie pentru acest vector particular.
Acum, dacă vrem să calculăm produsul interior între oricare doi din acești vectori
pentru unghiurile, alpha și beta să zicem, este
simplu de făcut asta.
Avem doar numere reale
în acești vectori, deci nu există
conjugate complexe de luat în considerare și obținem produsul cosinusurilor
plus produsul sinusurilor, și putem folosi una din
formulele de adunare a unghiurilor
pentru a simplifica aceea, este
cosinusul diferenței dintre unghiuri și
deoarece funcția cosinus
este simetrică față de zero,
nu contează de fapt în ce ordine le luăm.
Dacă nu ai aceste identități trigonometrice
memorizate, apropo,
nu ești singurul, dar nu trebuie să le reții,
le poți căuta. Aceasta are totuși sens
când te gândești la interpretarea geometrică
a produsului interior
între vectori unitari reali ca cosinusul unghiului dintre ei.
Dacă calculăm produsul
interior al produsului tensorial al oricăror doi din acești vectori
cu starea Phi plus, obținem o expresie similară
cu excepția că există un
rădăcina lui doi la numitor.
Aceasta este prima dată
când starea Phi plus apare în contextul
acestui exemplu, apropo, și vom vedea exact de ce suntem interesați
de acest produs interior particular în curând, dar pentru moment să
observăm că obținem aceeași expresie pe care am avut-o
pentru produsul interior împărțit
la rădăcina pătrată din doi și deci putem simplifica ca înainte.
În continuare, vom defini o
matrice unitară, U theta, pentru fiecare unghi theta
după cum poți vedea chiar aici,
nu este dificil să
verifici că aceasta este într-adevăr o matrice unitară.
Lucrul cheie pe care trebuie să îl
recunoaștem este că vectorii si theta este ortogonal față de
vectorul si theta plus pi peste doi, și asta are sens
deoarece, dacă rotim cu pi peste doi, adică 90 de grade, obținem un vector ortogonal.
Dacă înmulțim apoi U
theta cu U theta dagger, obținem matricea identitate.
Vorbind intuitiv,
ceea ce face această matrice ca o operație este să
mapeze si theta la ket zero și si theta plus pi doi la ket unu.
La acest punct, avem
tot ce avem nevoie pentru a descrie strategia lui Alice și Bob.
Mai întâi, exact ca la teleportare și superdense coding, Alice și Bob vor începe partajând un e-bit.
Alice deține un qubit A,
Bob deține un qubit B, și împreună cei doi qubiți
se află în starea Phi plus.
Acțiunile lui Alice sunt după cum urmează: ea se uită la bitul X pe care
îl primește de la arbitru,
și dacă X este egal cu zero,
ea efectuează U zero pe A, care se întâmplă să fie
același lucru cu a nu face nimic, deoarece U zero este matricea identitate,
dacă X este egal cu unu, pe de altă parte, aplică U pi peste patru la A.
După ce aplică una
din cele două operații, măsoară A folosind o
măsurătoare a bazei standard și trimite orice rezultat
pe care îl obține arbitrului.
Bob face ceva foarte similar, qubit-ul lui se numește B desigur, și primește Y de la
arbitru, spre deosebire de X,
dar diferența cheie este
că folosește unghiuri diferite pentru operațiile sale unitare.
Dacă Y este egal cu zero, el
aplică U pi peste opt, iar dacă Y este egal cu unu, aplică U minus pi peste opt.
Și vom vedea de ce aceste alegeri de unghiuri sunt alegeri bune în curând,
nu este deloc evident.
Și iată o diagramă circuit
care exprimă această strategie.
Bob este sus și Alice
este jos de data aceasta, iată e-bit-ul care intră
și acestea sunt gate-urile unitare
pe care Alice și Bob le-ar putea sau nu aplica
în funcție de X și Y.
Pentru acesta și acesta, avem gate-uri care sunt controlate fie de bitul X, fie de bitul Y
și pentru acestea două chiar aici, avem ce seamănă cu gate-uri de control, cu excepția că cercul nu este umplut.
Și asta înseamnă că
dacă bitul de control este setat la zero, atunci gate-ul este efectuat, iar dacă controlul este setat la
unu, atunci nu se întâmplă nimic.
Deci, este la fel ca un
gate de control obișnuit, cu excepția că rolurile lui zero și unu pentru control sunt inversate.
Deci, efectiv, Bob
efectuează acest gate chiar aici dacă Y este egal cu zero, el
efectuează acest gate chiar aici
WEBVTT
dacă Y este egal cu unu, și în mod similar, Alice efectuează acest gate chiar
aici dacă X este egal cu zero, și acest gate chiar aici,
dacă X este egal cu unu.
Aceasta este, deci, strategia lui Alice și Bob, și acum trebuie să
aflăm cât de bine funcționează.
Pentru analiza strategiei cuantice pe care tocmai am descris-o, avem de fapt nevoie doar de două lucruri la acest punct: mai întâi, matricea
unitară U Theta
este după cum o poți vedea chiar aici, și
al doilea am avut această formulă.
Nu mai avem de fapt nevoie de definiția vectorului si theta, aceste două ecuații sunt tot ce avem nevoie.
Există patru cazuri de
luat în considerare, începând cu cazul unu, care este X egal
zero și Y egal zero.
Și dacă ne uităm înapoi la strategie, vom constata că în acest
caz Alice efectuează U zero pe qubit-ul ei, iar Bob efectuează
U pi peste opt pe qubit-ul lui.
Ține minte, Alice este jos
și Bob este sus, deci starea pe care o
obțin arată astfel.
Și extinzând aceea
conform definiției lui U theta, obținem această
expresie pe care o poți vedea chiar aici.
Nu avem nevoie să extindem
aceea mai departe, deoarece avem cealaltă
formulă care ne ajută.
Și dacă aplicăm acea formulă
pentru fiecare din cei patru termeni, obținem aceasta.
La acest punct, Alice și Bob măsoară ambii, iar iată un tabel care
explică distribuția rezultatelor.
Luăm valoarea absolută
la pătrat a coeficienților pentru a obține probabilitățile, care se întâmplă să fie
pătratele coeficienților
deoarece coeficienții sunt
toți numere reale în acest caz.
Dacă folosim
valorile sinusului și cosinusului de mai devreme în lecție
împreună cu câteva simetrii, putem exprima aceste probabilități
după cum avem chiar aici
în ultima coloană.
Acum, ceea ce contează cu adevărat
este probabilitatea că ei câștigă, și ține minte că, în cazul în care X și Y sunt ambele zero,
câștigă dacă A și B sunt egali și pierd dacă A și B nu sunt egali.
Dacă calculăm acele probabilități, constatăm că probabilitatea
că A și B sunt egali este suma acestui număr și a acestuia,
care este egală cu doi plus
rădăcina lui doi totul împărțit la patru, adică aproximativ 85%.
Probabilitatea că A și B nu sunt egali este doi minus rădăcina lui doi totul împărțit la patru, care este în mod natural unu minus cantitatea
pe care tocmai am calculat-o, deci
câștigă cu probabilitate de aproximativ 85% în acest caz.
Mai sunt trei cazuri de luat în considerare, dar toate sunt foarte similare cu acesta,
în cazul în care X este egal cu
zero și Y este egal cu unu, Bob aplică U minus pi peste opt în loc de U pi peste opt,
valorile din
formule se schimbă oarecum, dar ajungem la exact
aceleași probabilități pe care le-am avut în cazul anterior.
Când X este egal cu zero și Y este egal cu unu, Alice și Bob câștigă în continuare
când A și B sunt egali, deci avem exact aceeași probabilitate de câștig
ca înainte.
În al treilea caz, când X este egal cu unu și Y este egal cu zero, avem o situație similară, unghiurile sunt diferite,
dar au exact
aceeași relație
unele cu altele, și de fapt obținem exact
același vector pe care l-am obținut în cazul anterior.
Deci probabilitățile sunt aceleași și la fel și probabilitatea de câștig.
Ultimul caz este puțin
diferit, cum ne-am putea aștepta, deoarece condiția de câștig
este diferită în acest caz.
Când X și Y sunt ambii egali cu unu, Alice și Bob câștigă când
A și B sunt diferiți.
Metoda de bază este aceeași, deși unghiurile sunt diferite, de data aceasta obținem acest vector chiar aici
și poți verifica asta parcurgând scăderile necesare.
Probabilitățile se schimbă în final, și dacă căutăm valorile de care avem nevoie, vedem că probabilitățile au efectiv
schimbat pozițiile față de înainte, deci de data aceasta este probabilitatea
că A nu este egal cu B, care este mai mare din cele două,
dar asta este bine, deoarece în acest caz, Alice și Bob câștigă când
A și B nu sunt egali.
Deci din nou, câștigă cu
probabilitate de aproximativ 85%.
Dat fiind că câștigă în fiecare
caz cu aceeași probabilitate, care este doi plus rădăcina lui doi
totul împărțit la patru sau aproximativ 85%,
aceasta este probabilitatea
că câștigă în general.
Aceasta este mai bună decât orice strategie clasică poate face pentru acest joc, și asta
este ceea ce îl face interesant.
Aceasta se întâmplă să fie
probabilitatea optimă de câștig pentru orice strategie cuantică, nu
poți face mai bine decât asta folosind orice stare entanglată.
Acel fapt este cunoscut ca inegalitatea Tsirelson, numită pentru Boris
Tsirelson care a demonstrat-o primul, și pe cât știu eu a fost
una din primele persoane
care a descris acest exemplu ca un joc. În caz că analiza
pe care tocmai am parcurs-o pare puțin misterioasă,
este posibil să te gândești
la asta geometric, ceea ce ar putea fi util
pentru a-ți oferi o mai bună înțelegere a alegerii unghiurilor.
În mod specific, dacă folosim
formula pe care o poți vedea chiar aici, pe care o putem deduce cu ușurință
din expresiile
pe care le-am găsit deja pentru
produsele interioare implicate, atunci putem exprima alternativ probabilitățile rezultatelor posibile ale măsurătorii
WEBVTT
în cele patru cazuri astfel: mai întâi, dacă X, Y este egal cu zero, zero, atunci acestea sunt probabilitățile
diferitelor rezultate ale măsurătorii, și trebuie fie să te gândești înapoi, fie să te uiți înapoi la analiza
pe care tocmai am parcurs-o pentru a concluziona folosind formula noastră.
Chiar aici, putem vedea
diferiții vectori de stare desenați ca mai devreme, iar codificarea prin culori este că albastru corespunde
rezultatului zero și roșu
corespunde rezultatului unu.
Poți vedea că unghiul
dintre vectorii albaștri și unghiul dintre vectorii roșii este relativ mic,
este pi peste opt în ambele cazuri, deci cosinusul este relativ mare, și asta înseamnă că probabilitatea că cele două rezultate
sunt egale este relativ mare.
În cazul în care X, Y este egal cu zero, unu, este o situație similară, unghiurile dintre vectorii cu aceeași culoare este mic,
deci probabilitatea de
rezultate egale este din nou, relativ mare.
Al treilea caz este similar, iar în al patrulea caz
când X, Y este egal cu unu, unu, ceva interesant se întâmplă,
de data aceasta, pur și simplu datorită modului în care
acești vectori au fost aleși, vedem că unghiurile dintre
vectorii cu aceeași culoare
sunt relativ mari, și în particular unghiurile sunt trei ori
pi peste opt în ambele cazuri.
Asta înseamnă că probabilitatea
că rezultatele măsurătorii sunt egale este relativ mică, dar acesta este cazul în care Alice și Bob câștigă
când răspunsurile lor diferă,
deci este ceea ce vrem.
Din nou, iată vectorii: când X, Y este egal cu zero, zero,
când X, Y este egal cu zero, unu,
când X, Y este egal cu unu, zero,
și când X, Y este egal cu unu, unu.
Și poate această imagine geometrică
este utilă în construirea unei intuiții
pentru modul în care funcționează această strategie
și de ce au fost aleși acești unghiuri în modul în care au fost.
Pentru a încheia lecția, voi face câteva observații scurte
despre jocul CHSH.
În primul rând, cum am menționat deja, acest exemplu nu este întotdeauna
descris ca un joc.
În comunitatea fizicienilor, de exemplu, este mai obișnuit ca
exemplul să fie descris pur și simplu ca un experiment, mai degrabă decât ca un joc
și Alice și Bob sunt
priviți ca detectori, mai degrabă decât jucători.
Ideea de bază a unui experiment de acest fel în care entanglementul duce
la rezultate statistice inconsistente cu
orice descriere clasică
sau mai general orice
teorie bazată pe variabile ascunse locale,
se datorează lui John Bell, cel care a dat numele stărilor Bell,
și astfel oamenii se referă adesea
la experimente de acest fel ca teste Bell.
Uneori oamenii se referă și
la teorema lui Bell, care poate fi formulată în diferite moduri, dar ea spune în principiu că mecanica cuantică
nu este compatibilă cu teoriile de variabile ascunse locale.
Jocul sau inegalitatea CHSH este în esență un exemplu foarte frumos și curat
al unui test Bell,
și poți gândi
la acest exemplu ca la o dovadă sau o demonstrație a teoremei lui Bell.
A doua observație este că jocul CHSH ne oferă o modalitate de a testa experimental că teoria informației cuantice
este o teorie exactă. Putem de fapt să configurăm experimente care implementează jocul CHSH,
inclusiv tipul de
strategie bazată pe entanglement pe care tocmai am descris-o, și
să vedem dacă funcționează, și funcționează.
Asta ne oferă un
grad ridicat de încredere că entanglementul este real, și spre deosebire de modurile poate
vagi sau poetice
în care încercăm să
explicăm entanglementul, jocul sau experimentul CHSH
ne oferă o metodă concretă
și testabilă de a observa entanglementul.
Dacă asta sună important,
este pentru că este, și Premiul Nobel 2022
pentru fizică recunoaște exact asta.
Premiul a fost acordat lui
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, care este C-ul din CHSH, și Anton Zeilinger
pentru experimente cu fotoni entanglați care au stabilit violarea
inegalităților Bell, sau cu alte cuvinte, care au arătat că strategiile cuantice
de tipul celui pe care l-am descris funcționează cu adevărat și depășesc strategiile clasice.
Și dacă ești interesat să
afli mai multe despre asta, te încurajez să urmărești
videoclipul despre teorema lui Bell al colegei mele Olivia Lanes,
chiar aici pe canalul de YouTube Qiskit.
Și în final, subiectul
jocurilor non-locale în general este cu adevărat fascinant și este
o zonă activă de cercetare
care aduce laolaltă
fizica, informatica și matematica pură și există încă multe
întrebări interesante
despre jocurile non-locale care
rămân fără răspuns până în ziua de azi.
Aceasta este sfârșitul lecției a patra, precum și sfârșitul
unității unu a seriei despre Bazele Informației Cuantice.
Prima lecție a explicat
cum funcționează informația cuantică pentru sisteme individuale izolate, iar a doua lecție a explicat
cum funcționează informația cuantică
pentru sisteme multiple,
ceea ce apare destul de natural din modul în care funcționează pentru sisteme individuale.
WEBVTT
A treia lecție a introdus
modelul de computație quantum circuit, iar în a patra lecție am analizat trei exemple importante
care ilustrează lucruri pe care le
putem face cu entanglementul.
Pe parcurs, am văzut câteva concepte matematice foarte importante,
inclusiv produse tensoriale și produse interioare, și am observat
câteva limitări fundamentale
ale informației cuantice.
Sper că te vei alătura mie
pentru unitatea următoare a seriei, care va fi despre algoritmii cuantici, unde ne vom concentra pe întrebarea
ce avantaje computaționale
oferă informația cuantică.
La revedere până atunci.